if you want to play a costume superhero
then you need to look the part
and that means intense workouts coupled
with an insane diet let's take a look at
how Zachary Levi went from super geek to
superhero and got ripped for Shazam
[Music]
when Zachary Levi agreed to take on
Shazam as his next big role he
essentially agreed to make the gym his
second home after all this is a
character who has stood his ground in a
number of scraps with Superman over the
years
if this confrontation is ever going to
play out on the big screen then Levi has
to at least keep pace with Henry Cavill
assuming cavil is still playing the Man
of Steel by the time a crossover is
viable the movies official synopsis even
described Shazam as having a ripped
god-like body so there's little wonder
Levi began hitting the weights almost
every day during a chat with former
Smallville Lex Luthor actor Michael
Rosenbaum Levi said he's working out
five or six days a week he elaborated
sometimes I'll do two a days and then
we'll get more off days but typically
we'll just go you know I own 50 minute
sessions every day that's a lot of time
in the gym no matter who you are and all
that time pumping iron definitely shows
when someone who doesn't work out
regularly starts hitting the gym hard
they usually experience what's known as
newbie gains yes you too can have a body
like mine if you don't careful this was
evidently the case for Levi who managed
to pack on an impressive amount of
pounds within his first six weeks of
training
he told Rosenbaum in February 2018 oh I
got the role I was about 200 pounds
hovered around 200 pounds most of my
adult life Levi gave a similar account
of his early gains when variety caught
up with him almost a year down the line
speaking to The Hollywood trade at the
New York City premiere of the marvelous
mrs. Mays old season two the actor
revealed that he'd started seeing
results right away I immediately put on
about twenty four pounds and then we
carved that down in about half so I've
been hovering around 215 pounds and I'm
in the best shape of my life and
stronger and happier and healthier than
I've ever been
I got into really good shape am i
hitting the light right what's happening
why it probably won't surprise you to
learn that Levi had to consume a heroic
amount of calories to achieve a Shazam
worthy physique
when variety quizzed him about his
weight gain at the marvelous mrs. Mazal
season 2 premiere the actor revealed
that he'd been taking on between 3,000
and 4,000 calories a day ever since he
won the lead role in the DC movie I mean
just walk down this peanut-brittle real
quick why would you do that all right
cuz calories Levi went on to give a more
detailed breakdown of his Shazam calorie
count during his appearance on Michael
Gross and Baum's podcast 3700 calories
with this then like a bunch of other
supplements like fish oil omega threes
it's an impressive amount of calories
for sure but how does it match up
against Levi's DC counterparts the short
answer is that well it doesn't both Ben
Affleck and Henry Cavill reportedly
consumed up to 5,000 calories per day
when training to play Batman and
Superman
Levi described his diet as pretty lean
and clean and he really wasn't kidding
to achieve his body goals the actor had
to give up some of his favorite snacks
and make every single mouthful count
which is why most of his meals consist
of protein rich chicken and large
portions of broccoli a favorite of
bodybuilders everywhere Levi was even
eating broccoli for breakfast at one
stage documenting the experience on
Instagram stories one bemused follower
took to Twitter to ask the actor why he
would do such a thing and Levi revealed
that he has a variation on chicken and
broccoli five times a day I basically
eat the same macros all day long meat
and veggie in combinations I used to eat
a lot of eggs in the morning but I think
I have an intolerance to them hopefully
that means he didn't have to down in the
raw egg shakes rocky style Levi's
physical transformation has clearly been
a source of inspiration to his fans with
some even reaching out to ask the actor
for hints and tips on getting jacked he
told one of his followers it's a
marathon not a sprint I have been in the
gym five days a week to the last five
months and I've eaten pretty darn
healthy strictly but not so crazy that
I'm not still enjoying life the system
works
when another fan asked how her skinny
husband could look more like Levi the
actor revealed that he himself used to
struggle with adding muscle to his
slender frame and it was all down to
diet
according to Levi you can work out
constantly but if you aren't providing
your body with
all the right tools then you're going to
struggle to improve on those newbie
gains the former chuck star replied the
key I found was quite literally
consuming mass quantities you have to
feed your muscles you have to give your
body the building material necessary to
grow larger
you have to eat even when you're not
hungry 14,000 calories later found
myself down at Subway powering through a
12-inch veggie on whole-wheat leave I
might advocate eating as much as humanly
possible but that doesn't mean eating
whatever you can get your hands on when
he was asked how he manages to eat well
while still enjoying his life he gave a
pretty straightforward answer avoid
processed foods from my perspective the
biggest favor you can do for yourself is
avoiding all processed foods sweet or
savory doesn't matter it's all breaking
down and your body is sugar that is then
stored as fat but there's a lot of tasty
clean food out there get into it why are
you eating stem first this is a new food
for me now well sir I eat it the other
way junk food is far from the only
obstacle when you're trying to balance
gym life with the social life however
alcohol certainly doesn't help matters
when you're trying to remain as trim as
possible please believe I discovered the
benefits of cutting out the foods when
he took part in sober October 2018 Starr
admitted it was a little difficult at
first and it's still kind of strange not
having a drink when I go out at night
but overall I feel so much healthier and
happier and clearer of mind and heart
it's been a good cleanse may even take
it longer
we'll see finding the time to prepare
five clean meals a day can be a big
challenge for anybody let alone a busy
actor but that's where having a major
Hollywood studio as your boss comes in
handy
Levi praise Warner Brothers for helping
him reach his targets when he spoke to
Michael Rosenbaum revealing that the
studio had arranged for his meals to be
brought right to his door he said I do
meal delivery it's part of the job and I
and they've been they've been very
awesome about taking care of me that's
all well and good but what does Levi do
when he's not home as an actor he has to
travel a lot but even then he sticks to
his regimented diet plan he tweeted I
used different meal delivery companies
in different cities because I need to
eat a lot throughout the day and
know how to cook like at all imagine
putting yourself through months of
training and hundreds of portions of
broccoli only for one of the biggest
names and fitness to call you a fraud
that's the situation Levi's found
himself in during March 2018 when Men's
Health suggested that the actor was
wearing a padded suit on set some
behind-the-scenes photos of Levi's in
full costume were leaked online and
regular contributor vide Mancuso took
one look at the size of Levi's biceps
and called foul play in response to the
Men's Health investigation Levi's posted
a picture of his bicep on Twitter along
with the caption so much padding it was
the actor's way of getting back at the
fitness mag but the author of the
original article wasn't convinced in
fact Denny Mancuso said the photo
Levi posted was actually evidence that
he was correct about the suit padding
all along in a follow-up article he said
yes that is a large arm that is a gym
earned above average sized appendage but
try to tell yourself honestly that the
arm in that photo is the same arm in the
leaked photo you can't you just can't do
it Levi has had a hard time shaking the
fake muscle rumors since his spat with
men's health some people seem to think
he looked padded out in a trailer that
dropped in January 2019 with one fan
questioning just how he looked so huge
the actor gave a purposefully
non-committal answer that's likely
because he's sick of addressing the
story by now when variety asked him
about it on the red carpet just a few
weeks earlier Levi's again denied that
he needed extra mass according to a
study by the Society of behavioral
medicine having a workout partner can
greatly improve your performance in the
gym doubling cardio results in some
instances while many superhero actors
are set up with world-renowned trainers
the guy spotting Levi is actually a
photographer by trade Eric Blackmon has
posted multiple pics and videos of
Levi's pumping iron unofficially
documenting the actor's progress in
October 2017 Blackman tweeted apparently
I'll be getting ripped for Shazam as
well since Zachary Levi is kicking my
ass in the gem I need protein now
despite the bleak winter weather the
pair remained dedicated to the Shazam
cause as
20:18 rolled around by February Levi was
already looking far more heroic in their
sessions and by May both men were
looking fighting fit Levi's replied to
the second men's health article with
another photo of his guns and this one
was harder to argue against the actor
posted a topless pic of himself in the
gym along with a hilarious equation it's
like the old saying goes hard work
overtime plus chicken and broccoli
- carbs / whey protein in which X
represents the amount of supplements and
Y represents the sentiment of why the
hell am i doing this to myself
x shameless selfies whilst staring into
nowhere talk about taking your workouts
to the next level is so hard to
understand
this is not when he spoke to variety in
December 2018 Levi was eager to discuss
how being selected to play the lead role
in Shazam changed his life in more ways
than one his name is now known across
the board in Hollywood and he likely
picked up a pretty paycheck for his work
on the Shazam movie but he was also
extremely grateful for the chance to get
healthy honestly that's the stuff that
I'm most ecstatic about just the level
of health that I've gotten to mental
health emotional health spiritual health
physical health
I am so jazzed about that and I want to
keep talking about that particularly
mental health it would have been easy
for Levi to give up after Men's Health
suggested that he just wasn't big enough
to play a superhero but he wasn't
working out for anyone but himself he
added I just feel like we're in a place
particularly nowadays where people need
to be encouraged and informed on what
self-love is and to go and genuinely
embrace themselves and love themselves
so I'm really happy about all of that
sorry
check out one of our newest videos right
here Plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you